[Music]
we're at Tatooine Mos Eisley but that
dream that the weim scum and villainy
are you traveling what does it say on
your thing 23 seconds 22 21 know what as
I said we're still global we're still
loading and we're still loading but
we're coming we're coming there I'm
gonna watch it twigs I just got out of
that game I just got out of that game
I know it's nicely again yeah we saw we
got how many knowing there is to play
with this [ __ ] I mean I didn't make any
money in [ __ ] San Jose man [ __ ] I
mean it's it's been a long time I mean I
only made 30 grand
it sucks oh god here we go my name's
dropping or something man here that's
like a four Pikachu we're the type of
heavy fingers you know what I should
have bought you the personnel it's not
even that bad it's so bad there's like
16 whiteheads on their hideout Pikachu I
don't know it's [ __ ]
tender green we gotta fill out maybe you
got stuck wearing hats right cause
you're wearing well we are you got there
I don't see you guys
we're common autumn Oh sighs Lee again I
know we're there [ __ ] oh there they are
yeah how many people can play the squad
on that 420 2018 nobody you can't and
shoot Bobby secure yeah the coat
junkyard that's what we're doing right
now do it yeah oh [ __ ] this guy just
gotta flip all these little all these
little things are behind it there's
somebody to the right Rock follow me
guys let me follow me guys this is got
captain capital the [ __ ] a poncho via
over here
no they're good in this mud terrain
I just died oh my god
disaster I should have followed Frank
goddamnit yes did pretty good on
battleground so oh my god I feel like if
Frank lived in the Star Wars universe
get live here right yeah and I'd work
for you cuz you'd also sound like those
critters they can you have glowing
glowing glowing eyes and wearing a robe
that's what you are you're a [ __ ]
cowboy doc man they haven't seen you
since like episode 2 what was that
[ __ ] flying thing one time funny if
you don't even know that yeah get to
explain it come on this man Frank's work
on us do we get a say yeah said nine
numbers so [ __ ] dude you gotta know what
was the Guido together Daniken worked
for oh my god I think correct would be
fat Emperor we already know each other
huh we already know what you would look
like I mean the most recent Star Wars we
already know that Emperor Palpatine for
like heart palpitations it's the fat
[ __ ]
I'm so sorry I have one for Frank just
we have to apologize for Frank where are
you guys we should be together
I'm in the cantina [ __ ] all right see
you oh [ __ ] me do you I'm oh there's a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh I almost got that guy
who's like dinosaurs and [ __ ] over here
like Jurassic Park in this [ __ ]
why can't you shoot them back up to the
cantina who's shooting me oh there's a
band right there in the van shooting
grenades at that guy how did he even
[ __ ] survive man
I have no battle points
you
they think they've made a lot of
improvements to this game I think it's a
lot better it's my man I don't play it
all day in Telesto
oh my god main ingredient what's the
point you have to speak achoo
[Music]
yes as long as I'm not last place you
don't I'm not a gold you guys yeah yeah
there's no way just don't bring the
hassle yes especially since you've been
playing all day yeah I'm [ __ ]
shooting that civilians and [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] flying around doing good
gotta go tiebreaker at you you're right
you're right
what is this Craig the playing destiny
oh they are
it's Pikachu good up destiny alright
alright I'm not the best not the
greatest now I'm not the best that's the
better than Craig no that's arguable
that's very arguable lay on the bottom
Craig I'm first thing you didn't win
that last round was all up to you I
haven't I haven't run into one enemy
oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] shooting at my own
guys
oh [ __ ]
oh there's a girl [ __ ]
oh my god there's an emperor right here
not doing [ __ ] I'm not a MOT whole how
many how many battle points do you have
Bobby I have I don't know because I
can't tell what's good on or not on this
shut
damn it scares boys I still don't know
where you got oh yeah I just died again
you guys are way away from me oh that's
a four thousand of us it's like we're
not even playing together we don't have
we all the same keep it up to be
together you came you want to cuddle
yeah we should be suddenly Oh [ __ ]
dude
oh you thought you're the worst
I forgot how incredibly forgot how what
forgot how [ __ ] is ugly come on
thank you
why am i shooting my own guy come on
crank not that far behind
let's have to make me hot
Oh God
yeah baby
I finally got some kills man Wow oh
there's a bunch of Emperor's flying
around holy [ __ ] it's getting real in
there yeah man this is bombs and [ __ ]
going off oh my god
I'm the last [ __ ] Guardian smoke okay
come on come on Craig it's only two
people do you ever wait for the yellow
you know when you're doing this thing
what you know like you making food
become a yellow the blue no the blue or
the yellow you know you know when you're
really - I'm [ __ ] lagging goes on the
bottom people don't go down go down go
down without without pink I'm trying to
load who is on the bottom glad for candy
oh [ __ ] this guy's Oh watch it was gone
barely where I know he's dead [ __ ] just
that Yoda is the worst like there's just
no stopping Yoda that's how it should be
ceptin episode 3 when he just give up
for no reason no you know Bobby's mom
with Master Yoda I don't know if you
guys know that no but your mom she
didn't get the part but she tested for
Yoda but her [ __ ] worked great for the
Ewoks you know I mean it was like it's
gonna be back with Bobby everybody
twitch page okay well I don't know how
to do that so just be glad I even have
this what are we supposed to be doing
when I don't even know the objective
this day right here we're trying to
defend this area that's all
I want just do an awesome grenade will
give me yelling at my last love just
foolin
oh my god okay there's a Luke over here
wrecking [ __ ] I know there's a look over
there man oh I thought I was dead
oh yeah watch out hey Derek when you
pick me here he should fit you should be
a fat Lando like the next season of love
it just got canceled
that was a good one do we win yeah we
did it but we got last place you did oh
my god you want that I like
are we gonna be the good guys now or
actually there's no such I don't know
man I just keep switching and I get this
new matter oh you should have last week
it was cheap man last one I got it it
was like any books yeah it was only $30
should I get it looking for though yeah
no fun to nobody
always gonna play with us is your mom
gonna give you enough allowance so I
guess the only game I can play
Pikachu's got to get his own one he's
gotta get his allowance first Pikachu
yeah he's got to get his allowance you
know from yeah I'm just paper route how
many people listen to your [ __ ] uh oh
no why do you have it yeah yeah we
caught we copy the [ __ ] man I don't like
this heavy gun with the two titties on
that's your only goal [ __ ]
to them clean the resurrection thing now
on the other the fishin is hard man
nice Pikachu good job Pikachu there's a
campaign mode it's [ __ ] hard yeah
yeah I already got a kill
where are these [ __ ] rockets man
oh [ __ ] but big big Walker is [ __ ]
shooting at us
all these things are way over here Jesus
Christ there's so far away man
not ganna shut the [ __ ] up breathing
[ __ ] breathe okay you know what I
can't wait to start your [ __ ] Pikachu
breathing not that Pikachu I want the
real ones how's that guy Oakley killing
me for it
thank you
oh my god but you've run out of ammo
Steve have Battleford yeah
whoa
pick that thing up and [ __ ] use it
I'm trying I can't even get to it every
time I try to hop on it God oh here we
go
[Applause]
there we go all somebody picked it up
oh it was great oh my God look at the
hassle
[ __ ] you got him all my gum dying every
[ __ ] five senses a warble no strikes
Oh
[ __ ] chill just go oh my god I'm
[ __ ] out
that damn and being terrible
laughter the Pikachu oh my god I'm here
I just can't talk what's the point
he's pulling a Steve got yelled at by
mom told you Pikachu's okay there's that
one I have one Walker is it
how is that guy not dead there's so much
battle from this oh my god they just
vanish man no I have it now on me okay
oh wow I just got wrecked
we're a team
all back with me is this and fall back
already take out those lockers oh
there's a ray over here just they don't
know what they're doing because they're
just like oh my god an orbital strike
it's just [ __ ] me up man like I want
an orbital strike who does the orbital
strike the officers know it's orbital
from the sky you have to be a spaceship
no no no orbital strikes are those
things you use that like binoculars type
thing help the state
thanks buddy
[Applause]
just first game why God like that tactic
of taking the a dad on right in the
front
oh my god
oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] up that's one of those
things oh there's a Yoda over here with
us oh where we have to oh [ __ ] we got to
fall back
are you guys inside were you guys that
yeah we're on the side this I don't know
if you're in yet
there's a Darth Vader coming
turn back of us there in back of us oh
[ __ ]
oh my god kill me now
just kill me got you back
what
[Music]
Oh inovative hey after this game I'm
gonna go wash my face right it makes you
use some moisturizer for those pimples
Bobby got heroic sacrifice they just
said that just made you suck have you
been a hero yet in this game I could be
a wookie warrior I don't know I can't if
I want to but they get used up yeah
Oh oh man
say I wanna tear solos that'll fun oh
come on you bought it
yep I did get it just gonna see you
Wednesday how long it goes a crinkly win
this like maybe if you were talking not
washing your face AHA he's gonna be
looking in the mirror right now just
like crying like my faith is Italy [ __ ]
you Bobby Lee [ __ ] you I'm just washing
it Skirving really hard yeah good job
Pikachu
I can never see anyone bump
there's a wookie warrior and array over
here
Nate out
he's gone to the thing he's got sword
victory oh [ __ ] idiot I know I did
horrible on that one how do you already
see the last place ago how do you know
if you press the out let the start
button but the other button shows you
examine the fun of your controller the
one to the left can you what you're
playing oh yeah oh that's ridiculous
I took seventh is that good no it's
better than point yet I rather be 2007
because it's like at least I know I
because I know I'm horrible you're seven
and still horrible but you think you're
good you know I mean so it's like
overconfident it's just better to be
down on the bottom sheet Frank
Oh Frank Frank so alive yeah alright I
got one more in me here all right I'm
done twitching - no more twitch bye-bye
everybody
say goodbye to Bobby the special guest
Bobby Lee is now gone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]